- Hey Frank.
- Kenny, how the hell are you?
I hate that man.
Takes up too much time in the coffee line.
Wears flip flops on casual Friday.
Sucks up to the boss
like it's his damn job.
Who the hell does that?
- Frank?
- Do you have the report?
- Why are we meeting back here?
What's this?
- It's our main means of
communication from here on out.
Till we meet again.
- Thank you.
- Anybody got a napkin?
- No.
- Excuse me.
- Did you just take my salad?
- I put it back.
- I know he did not just take my salad.
- Hey Frank, did you see the email?
Free lunch.
- Oh I sure did.
Who the hell does he think I am?
Some whore in post-war Berlin
salivating over stockings
and free chocolates?
- What?
- In this company knowing
your way around Excel is sex
and let's just say, I make
a damn good spreadsheet.
- So this is her?
- Yes.
- So nice to finally meet you.
- She knows?
- [Frank] Of course.
- Don't worry, I'm having three affairs.
Mike, Brian, and Andrew.
- [Frank] We do it to get
ahead in this company.
- Except Brian, he's just hot.
- Are you serious?
- And how does she benefit us again?
- Office supplies.
- I don't appreciate
how you treated Jackie
today at the water cooler.
- She'll be fine.
- She already suspects we're not
for her market research idea.
- Do you guys want another cup?
- Don't you understand
the symbolism of this?
- It's very sexual.
- White people.
- You're doing a great job Frank.
Really glad to have you on the team.
I better watch out, you
might have my job soon.
- I have him right where I want him.
Vulnerable, unknowing, in my cross hairs.
Now it's just a matter of
deciding when to strike.
- I can hear you.
- No he can't.
- Yes I can.
- Not how this works.